hello there very good evening to you
you're watching the Press preview of
first I got what's on the front pages as
they arrive for you tomorrow morning so
let's start or time to see what's making
headlines with the economist Carol
Malone the political editor as well of
the Liverpool Echo Liam Thorpe join us
tonight they're going to be with us all
the way to midnight this evening so
let's start by finding out what's on
some of those front pages and we'll
start with the daily mail it says
despite growing NHS waiting lists the
mail reports that GPS are demanding that
in future they work just nine to five
the I tomorrow says is likely to be
conflict in the cabinet over plans to
withhold visas from foreign students
pursuing what are described as low
quality degrees in an effort to reduce
net migration that's also the lead in
the times tomorrow now the telegraph
says that Boris Johnson and Liz truss
are planning to challenge the authority
of new PM Rishi sunak by demanding an
end to the ban on new wind farms
according to the financial times
tomorrow Ukrainian
has insisted Russia's attack on its
power grid infrastructure will not
ultimately succeed the guardian says MPS
want an investigation into claims
against Tory Pier baroness moan about
payments that she allegedly received
from her ties to a PP manufacturer
during the pandemic there are
allegations that she has denied at the
sun reports that David walliams is to
leave his judging role on Britain's Got
Talent it comes after off air footage
emerged showing him making derogatory
sexual remarks about a contestant
the Metro predicts that 30 million pints
of beer will be drunk during England's
World Cup match against the United
States tomorrow while the star believes
that many people will use it as an
excuse to take the day off work Heaven's
not
a quick reminder as well for you that by
scanning the QR code on the screen that
you'll see during the course the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch with
us so do give that one a go and as I say
wouldn't join tonight by Carol Malone
and Liam Thorpe welcome to you both
thank you so much for joining us so late
on a Thursday evening let's have a look
at what's caught your eye Carol let's
start with you the front page of the
telegraph this is big news isn't it the
nurses striking the first national
strike by nurses what walking tellers
yeah I mean they've said they're going
to go on strike for two days I mean this
really
fear for what's going to happen if they
if they if they do stage this drink I
think it's a Rubicon that if they cross
people will perhaps never see them in
the same way ever again you know
It Strike the whole it's also what
nurses stand for would be solid now I
know that a lot of them are complaining
that their pay is low I mean they start
on 27 Grand when you're seeing it goes
up to 55 grand a year and a lot of the
agency nurses are actually not doing too
badly they're on 68 Grand a year but the
the bottom line is I I just think you
know this is different this is if a
nurse walks out lives could be lost if
the posters go on strike your letters
and Parcels don't get delivered if the
rmt goes on strike you know you don't
get a train this is entirely different
and and it's the first strike in their
history and I really really don't want
them to do it am I saying that I think
nurses should be better people than than
all the rest of them yes I suppose I am
because I think we've all grown up with
the idea that nursing is a vocation and
if they go on strike it would feel like
it's not a vacation because they're
walking out on people who need to be
cared for there's a there's a very
interesting piece written by a nurse the
other week and I just want to read you
what she said she's she says she's not
going to go uh on strike and she said
you know SWAT strike action really means
she says I'm talking about the hands not
held the small compassionate gestures
not done or the words of comfort not
spoken to grieving relatives now that to
me a sums up everything a nurse is about
and if they walk on strike
that's not going to happen and and I
fear for for their reputation if they do
it let's bring you in now that the dead
Telegraph goes on to say that the RCN
says it's calling this strike after the
UK government turned down its offer of
formal
um negotiations or detailed negotiations
they said they've basically got no other
option now
um where do you where do your reader sit
on this where do you sit on this
yeah I would be fairly confident I'm
pretty in line with the thoughts of my
readers which is to 100 back uh these
striking nurses you know what I I
wholeheartedly disagree with what Carol
just said and I think the whole point of
stressing just how absolutely vital
someone is to our society to the health
of our people is that they it's the
point that's proving the point that they
should be paid correctly these people
will not be taking this action lightly
you don't go into to nursing to to go on
strike of course so you don't go into
nursing to be operating in the the the
critical situation that they are at the
moment I've spoken to several nurses who
are going on strike and the situation
that they explain to me is is really
Bleak there's nurses using food banks
food banks being set up in hospitals so
that nurses can can get by there's
people they're completely overworked
that story about the food banks goes
around a lot and I don't know whether
you've been looking at social media
everything there's a lot of nurses going
on social media saying that you know the
money they get means they don't they're
not using food banks they're on between
30 and 40 Grand a year I literally spoke
to it to a nurse on the phone who was
being forced to use but there's lots of
more than one actually that's what I
spoke to more than one and they're not
they're not making it up
finished Liam come back in Carol Carol
let Liam have a more time please
so yeah some some perhaps some aren't
using food bank but the fact that any
nurses who are working full-time in this
country in this Rich economy that we
live in in the National Health Service
are being forced to use food banks or
even contemplate using food banks whilst
working you know their back sites off to
try and keep us safe as they did
throughout the pandemic by the way you
know let's not forget the absolute
heroism that they did through the
pandemic and now they want to be able to
live like the rest of us they're
struggling they want to be able to pay
their bills they want to be able to feed
their families and they will not have
taken this action lightly yes there are
going to be safeguards in place around
urgent care and critical care but they
know they know that this action is going
to have consequences the NHS is already
on its knees and they know that
postponing more appointments and and and
operations and surgeries and things like
that is going to be a big problem so
they're not taking it lightly just like
everyone else in every other sector's
not taking it lightly if you if you
believe our nurses are absolutely vital
then pay them properly okay I'll just
move on it's absolutely true the
compassion and the Good Will of nurses
have has been exploited by success of
governments however I don't believe it
is the right thing to do to walk out on
sick people you've just said there
safeguards will be in place but there
will be consequences would you be would
you be so carefully about talking about
those consequences Liam if it was
someone in your family who suffered
those consequences because I wouldn't
and I just think if you go into nursing
okay I'm gonna jump in because we want
to have a look at what else is going on
in the papers it is a massive story and
it's going to dominate I'm sure the news
tomorrow but Carol is it's not just
nurses is it look at the front page of
the guardian and we saw what's happening
in Scotland today you've got teachers
striking uh postal workers striking
Railway workers striking and not just uh
School staff as well as teachers and
lecturers I mean are we heading for a
winter of discontent in this country
according to the guardian
it's kind of looking like we are and
it's you know it kind of
so do you see do you disagree with with
everyone striking or is it just nurses
yeah they all are they all Liam let
Carol finish
let me finish
um I don't necessarily disagree with
Postman Striker because I think their
salaries are a lot lower than a lot of
the rmt workers
um and nurses I
I think it's a shame that the the
teachers in Scotland are going on strike
kids have missed so much school in the
last two and a half years and to go out
on strike is actually not helping you
know I think you know a lot of the the
amounts that the people are asking for a
lot of the races they're asking for
inflation busting pay Rises that is not
going to happen that can't happen and if
it does happen legislation is going to
be with us for years to come inflation
will not go down with that house some of
the demands are unrealistic and and I
just you know I think the rmt's demands
are unrealistic they're asking for
between seven and eight percent it's not
gonna happen you know
look at what
how I can imagine how would the
government if they're doing that to us
how are they going to be able to pay all
these inflation boosting pay Races they
literally can't unless
seven or eight percent isn't inflation
busting it's considerably below where
inflation is running at the moment is
still unrealistic the alternative to
this is that people people are becoming
destitute people who are working hard
becoming destitute there is there is
more money in these in these networks as
as the rmt have pointed out there is
more money in the train system in the
train service and actually for the first
time in a while we've got we've had a
transport secretary who's actually sat
down with the rmt and is talking about
moving towards a deal the government has
just not wanted to engage with the
unions at all up until this point they
obviously want to you know Richie soon
I've mentioned it every time at pmqs
tries to hold up this idea of Union
Barons but what you have to always
remember is behind the unions behind the
union leader are successful votes from
Members these are these are everyday
workers whether it's nurses posties
what is the percentage of the rmt that
has to vote for strike action it is not
the entire workbook what does it mean
it has to it nobody has to be it has to
pass a certain threshold those are the
rules
I'm gonna dump it again because I want
to have a look at one final uh paper
before we go to the break and that's
onto the Daily Mail GPS voting to shut
doors at just 5 p.m uh Liam what's all
this about
yeah I mean so so this one has just come
through from from the mail this evening
and you know it I mean it isn't going to
help the situation with the NHS we know
that we know that obviously people are
um who currently are struggling to get
GP appointments are ending up in
hospital in a e you know I've done quite
a lot of reporting recently from
completely overcrowded a e departments
now many people requiring Emergency
Services some people are not and they
simply can't get a GP appointment I
don't know if anyone else is around here
has tried to get GPA appointment
recently it's it's now on Impossible
this story in the mail is saying that
the um GPS voted last night to limit
their hours to opening between 9am and 5
PM saying that longer working longer
working days will discriminate against
their families I don't know the full
details of it but obviously it's going
to have a knock-on effect to that kind
of primary care situation with hospitals
what we don't need obviously is more
people who perhaps don't need to turning
up a a a and which is already massively
massively overcrowded Carol you're
shaking ahead we're going to get your
response in just a minute because we've
got to go to a break to stay still and
we'll come straight back to you after
that thanks so much for that well as net
migration increases again we're going to
ask whether the government has the right
idea about how to deal with it do stay
with us here on Sky News
[Music]
hi there welcome back you're watching
the Press preview with us now is a Carol
Malone and Liam Thorpe welcome back to
both of you Carol let's just come back
to you regarding the front page of Daily
Mail I know you've got a point you want
to make regarding this headline that
says GPS vote to shut doors at just 5 PM
GPS voting last night to limit their
hours to nine o'clock to 5 p.m claiming
that longer working days discriminate
against those with families what point
would you like to make on that
it astonishes me you know if you if you
want to work nine to five don't go into
medicine I would imagine most GPS have
families have kids they knew exactly
what they were going into when they
started medicine it is not a scientified
job and I suggest the people who think
it should be are possibly in the wrong
job and the reason we seem to have a
shortage of GPS is because 60 percent of
only work three days a week I find it I
find that astonishing you know most of
them are I think the average salary is
something like 119 Grand a year
presumably they're still getting that if
they're working three days a weekend if
not they're getting something close to
it so you know it's not that we don't
have enough GPS it's the one we have are
choosing not to work five days we can
some stats came out yesterday that said
44 of all appointments at Doctor
surgeries are not with GPS they're with
nurses and health Physicians and physios
so why aren't the doctors seeing people
face to face why in the worst performing
surgeries are just 12 of patients being
seen face to face it's it's it's
disgraceful you know they were saying
eighty percent of people face to face
before covert what's happened since then
we haven't lost GPS we've actually
gained GPS by 1.5 let's move on let's
move on we've got lots of papers to get
through thank you the cow on to the eye
uh and of course on the day that we had
the news that net migration has reached
an all-time record Board of 504 000 a
year despite of course government
pledges to crack down on arrivals Liam
we hear that there's going to be a
student visa Crackdown which is set to
spark a major cabinet row what do you
make of this
yeah it looks like um it's got a few
potential
um rails on his Horizon I think we may
talk about another one later yeah just a
few um in his in trade this is um you
know it's particularly relevant as you
say with that news about that record net
migration today and an enormous number
of numbers portion of that number it was
was students overseas students we know
that obviously post pandemic as well
we've seen a rise in people coming over
to study and you know part of the UK's
sort of selling point is it's a huge
it's a huge selling point is that
students want to come here and get a
good education so it's it's it's a
difficult one at the moment as well for
the government because obviously there
is a real issue in terms of Labor
shortages in terms of the effect that
dare I say that brexit is having on the
economy in terms of people coming in and
working here in different types of jobs
yes yes there might be record migration
but there's not necessarily people
coming into all the types of jobs that
were required that are required if you
look at say Hospitality areas like that
where the free movement of the European
Union meant that lots of people were
coming into work in those Industries and
we currently can't get the people to
come in and work in those areas you may
often have got people who are coming in
who were students who would pick up jobs
in the hospitality area as well so what
the story in the eye is saying is that
the treasury is worried that if there is
a cap on student visas that's going to
harm the economy we know that Zoella
Braverman is under pressure to bring
these numbers down she obviously thinks
one way to do that is to is is kind of
she's determined to act on student visas
I'm not necessarily sure that that's
that's going to work because the
government needs need people to be
coming into the country and contributing
to the economy right now so it's a real
headache for the government and against
the backup of that that large figure
they seem to be going after students I'm
not sure that's what they what what
everyone in the cabinet is going to
agree on I think a lot a lot of
universities need foreign students to
come over in terms of paying these much
much higher tuition fees I mean what do
you think about this carol um I'll
always set up for a serious Rift in
government according to swella Bradman
well I think what's where abroad was
talking about is students coming to do
what she calls low quality degrees and
so that's what she wants to put an
engine I mean something like 485
000 the response of 4.5 000 sponsored
visas last year there's been an increase
of 71 in student visa since 2019. I mean
that's
and the argument is a lot of the
students who
are bringing dependents and then the
dependents bring more members of a
family and so it isn't just the students
it's all their immediate family as well
and and they stay so I think that's what
they're looking at today you know the
the migration figures we have you know
as soon as was saying today that a lot
of those were to do with a lot of the
the Afghans and ukrainians we that came
here in the last 12 months and it is
absolutely right and proper that we take
care of those people they really are are
genuine refugees and we have to take
care of those and that's not illegal
that's that's exactly what Britain
should be doing looking after the people
who are fleeing war and Terror so so yes
there is enough search this year but on
on stuff like the student visas which
seems to be like out of control I think
more than half of the student visas are
granted to to the Indians and the
Chinese they took up most of them so
that's one thing they can actually do
something about they have some control
over that so maybe what that's why
they're looking to that area
and just very briefly if you don't mind
Liam Davidoff says he's going to be
putting on the government pressure to
get net migration down to 100 000 a year
is it possible do you think very briefly
Liam
I think that was what David Cameron was
saying wasn't it quite quite a few years
ago I think um you know Karma it's a
good point these These are extraordinary
figures they are EXT you know it is a
sort of unique circumstance with both
the the Ukraine situation Afghanistan
and Hong Kong all of that come together
with a post-pandemic right yeah thank
you Carol we'll get more from you at the
top of the hour are you watching skies
at 10 see you in just a few minutes time
more from the papers